[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a analizar la situación de la
planta de energía nuclear ucraniana de
sap orilla la segunda más la más grande
de europa mejor dicho y ocupada por los
rusos desde el inicio de la guerra una
invasión que esta semana cumplirá ya
seis meses la central está en el centro
de las preocupaciones actuales de la
comunidad internacional pues se ha
registrado ataques con misiles en
cercanías de sus instalaciones ataques
de los que tanto rusos como ucranianos
se han culpado mutuamente esta tensa
situación ha llevado al líder
internacionales y también el secretario
general de la onu abogar por una
desescalada que evite que se produzca un
desastre nuclear que amenaza con ser
peor que el que ocurrió en chernóbil en
1986 y manuel macrón y también en
vladimir putin acordaron el viernes el
envío de una misión de la oea a esta
zona saludamos entonces a iván lópez
miralles analista de política al chrome
especializado en política exterior iván
muy buen día gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de francia
24 de pregunta entonces qué tan grave es
esta situación actual entorno a la
planta de sap orilla
bueno muchas gracias a ustedes por
contar conmigo el día de hoy creo que en
primer lugar hay que tener en cuenta que
todo todo lo que toda la actividad
militar que tenga alrededor y una
central nuclear es preocupante no tanto
rusos como ucranianos están utilizando
la situación como una batalla
informativa no generé específicamente
para ganar para intentar ganar tiempo de
ganar y ganarse a la opinión pública y
bueno hemos visto también algunas
imágenes por medio de fuentes de
inteligencia abierta que parece señalar
que hay equipo militar ruso estacionado
dentro de la central nuclear no sabemos
cuál puede ser el alcance y hay que ver
también cómo se desarrolla ese acuerdo
entre vladimir putin y manuel macrón
para enviar una misión de la oea para
ver qué que realmente está pasando
dentro de la central y cómo puede ser al
alcance
de lo que estamos viendo esos posibles
ataques no entre ucrania recursos en las
emigraciones de la central claro que
tanto digamos puede entonces lograr esta
misión de la oea a la planta nuclear de
shapur y allá
bueno la situación más idónea sería que
rusia se retirara de la de la central y
se estableciera una misión de la oea
permanente dentro de la provincia
nuclear y pudiera haber algún tipo de
seguridad no porque yo creo que esto es
lo más importante que no haya ningún
tipo de
error de cálculo no que pueda llevar a
un tipo de accidente nuclear y que al
fin y al cabo los más perjudicados van a
ser los que estén estacionados dentro de
las inmediaciones de la central y
posteriormente que se pueda ver afectado
algún país cercano como rumanía o
hungría y también tenemos que ver al
alcance de si la otan llega a activar
ese artículo 5 no en el caso de que se
lamente se lleva a cabo una fuga porque
como bien sabes las líneas rojas muchas
veces son flexibles se puede decir que
la otan va a intervenir pero tenemos que
ver cuál va a ser al alcance cuál va a
ser esa intervención si nos pusiésemos
en un escenario donde si se llevase a
cabo una una fuga nuclear no claro y en
caso digamos de un accidente le quiero
preguntar cómo esto afectaría a ucrania
rusia y también europa
en el caso más concreto de rusia y
ucrania se supondría un punto de
inflexión en la guerra pero el mayor
punto de inflexión que pueda haber no
rusia ha estado diciendo por medio de
sus medios estatales que para ellos no
tendría un problema paciente nuclear
porque tienen trajes especiales bueno
esto la medida un poco vamos a decir
básica pero a nivel a nivel de europa
estamos hablando de que podríamos
presentar un necesario similar a
chernóbil y también hay que ver como la
otan va va a reaccionar hemos visto que
varios de sus
funcionarios han estado diciendo que se
activaría el artículo 5 de respuesta
tendríamos que ver cómo es esa respuesta
since intervendría la otan directamente
en un cráneo para asegurar un tipo de
raptores más o algún tipo de asegurar la
zona
yo creo que esto es un escenario muy
lejano todavía yo creo que vamos a ver
como si va a haber un tipo de des
escalada y van a asegurarse este tipo de
instalaciones críticas claro y también
cómo se podría mitigar pues un desastre
como éste no estarían realmente
preparados para un riesgo de este tipo
de los países involucrados
yo creo que no
básicamente porque en este tipo de
escenarios están muchos sobre el papel
pero yo creo que todavía no hay un plan
estratégico en marcha de mitigación de
impacto en el caso de una fuga nuclear
básicamente porque yo creo que desde las
fuentes de inteligencia de los países
europeos de estados unidos y también de
ucrania y rusia no contempla actualmente
un desastre nuclear yo creo que estamos
viendo mucha batalla informativa batalla
por ganar el relato y al fin y al cabo
es una batalla estratégica por ver 15 de
antes hacia a cabo rusia y está esta
zona dentro del interior de la central
nuclear tiene un activo estratégico es
decir puede utilizarla como instalación
de respaldo para atacar a ucrania sin
teniendo bastante
tienes está bastante asegurado de que
ucrania no va a devolver de la misma
forma los ataques de rusia en esa misma
instalación y eso es lo que básicamente
rusia quiere no tener un tipo de
instalación de respaldo que le permita
ganar la batalla a ucrania en este caso
específico claro iván y en ese orden de
ideas también rusia amenazó con
desconectar esta planta de la red
eléctrica de ucrania las implicaciones
que esto podría tener en el sur del país
de cara al invierno que ya va a llegar
en tres meses aproximadamente
sí yo creo que este es otro escenario
que hay que tener en cuenta cuando
llegue el invierno
ucrania ya llevaba diciendo mucho tiempo
que los avances estratégicos para
reconquistar varias partes del país
tenían que llegar antes porque si no en
el invierno ucr ante esta situación
puede pasarlo realmente mal y ucrania
perdón y rusia puede llevar a cabo
grandes avances estamos hablando de que
si hubieran a recuperarse esta central y
enviarse electricidad a toda europa
sería un avance muy importante para
ucrania digamos y también ya como para
ir finalizando nuestra conversación que
tanto interfiere digamos la tensión que
hay dentro de la planta porque
recordemos que si bien es cierto los
rusos tienen el control esta ayuda igual
manera operada por los ucranianos que
siempre le han operado entonces como
esto también juega en contra digamos de
toda una seguridad nuclear
si evidentemente aquí la seguridad entre
actores está realmente comprometida
porque al fin y al cabo como tú bien
dices estamos hablando de que están
rusos y ucranianos manejando la central
nuclear yo creo que lo más prudente va a
ser cómo se desarrolla la misión de la
oea dentro de la central nuclear y se
llegue a algún tipo de acuerdo entre
rusia ucrania y la hoya de cara a
asegurar estas instalaciones críticas yo
creo que va a ser
al menos lo más prudente en este sentido
ahora bien estamos viendo como ucrania
también está mandando mensajes de que si
comienzan los juicios a los resistentes
de la dea soft salen mauri paul y
esto puede llevar a un cese completo de
todo tipo de negociación y aquí sí que
podemos leer como
puede haber algún tipo de altercado en
este sentido y pese a las amenazas de
selenski digamos ya igual dijeron que
este juicio se va a llevar a cabo en
todo caso hay que esperar a ver cómo se
van a desarrollar los hechos y pues
también que tanto puede hacer esta
misión de la oea hace orilla